[Musique]
la quatrième mesure la plus importante
les mika c'est à dire les mesures de
contrôle tous les détenus actuels qui
ont été condamnés après 2016 sont sous
le couvert de la nouvelle loi qui permet
effectivement des mesures de suivi
judiciaire pour faits de terrorisme mais
tous ceux qui sont rentrés avant 2016 ne
sont pas dans le champ de la loi
en clair une centaine de détenus vont
sortir de prison après avoir purgé leur
peine dans que sont payé leur dette à la
société entre guillemets sauf que tout
le monde sait qu'une partie d'entre eux
présente une dangerosité pour la société
et nous n'avons pas de mesure donc nous
avons proposé une mesure complémentaire
prononcée par le juge
destiné à protéger la société sont des
mesures d'assignation à résidence
d'assignation dans le périmètre d'une
commune de pointage dans une gendarmerie
ou dans un commissariat de police d'
interdiction d'aller à l'étranger
d'interdiction de rencontrer telle ou
telle personne évidemment le sénat est
dans son rôle puisqu'il a été
l'initiateur de la loi s'ils de proposer
des mesures complémentaires
on peut vous dire que côté du parquet
national anti terroriste s'ils sont très
demandeurs d'ailleurs le procureur l'a
dit dans la presse de cette mesure peut
dire que du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur aussi côté de ministère de
la justice mais c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
l'évolution se fait plus lentement parce
qu'évidemment le souci c'est de faire
des mesures constitutionnelles
mais la proposition de loi que je
présenterai comprendra une mesure dont
nous avons vraiment vérifier qu'elle
présentait toutes les garanties
suffisantes pour être constitutionnelles
[Musique]